hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his rhetoric book two analysis of the
emotions when he turns to the opposite
of anger proudes in greek which we
translate as mildness or calmness one of
the things that aristotle is going to do
is
look at who we typically
feel this towards and he's going to
examine in some cases why
that's the case a lot of this as he
points out can be understood by looking
at anger itself
and arguing or reasoning from opposites
that is if people get angry for this
reason
and you take away that reason then
they're they're liable to be
calm and so in some cases calmness is
going to be a
lack or privation of anger
reflected in these different situations
and people in other cases it's going to
be a
calming
or
becoming mild of anger you start out
angry and you become less so or indeed
perhaps not even not so not angry by the
time that this is done so there's a
number of different classes of people
there's nothing that prevents these by
the way from overlapping to some degree
and most of these i think we can agree
with there's a few that i'm going to
point out where we might say
aristotle i don't really know about that
your reasoning doesn't seem to be
entirely on point but we'll get to those
in just a bit so first he talks about
people who don't slide that is they they
don't
belittle or insult or show spite to us
or they don't do so voluntarily right
things go contrary to their expectation
they were trying to make it to our
recital but they got caught in
bumper-to-bumper traffic because of an
accident when we find this out then
we're less angry at them for missing the
event right or they tried their best to
make a wonderful cake for somebody's
birthday but they misread the list of
ingredients and they put in
far too much salt
like
they didn't understand the difference
between teaspoons and tablespoons in
recipes and it comes out and you're like
oh this is terrible right and then
they're like oh well i tried my best
okay so then you don't get uh angry with
them
and aristotle throws in something very
important here he's got this little
uh quip where he's like or
um
it doesn't appear
to be
so right uh
phenomenois right
so
why throw that in because anger is in
many respects um
a matter of our
assumptions our perspective perceptions
our imaginations
so
if somebody does slight us
but we don't think that they are then
we're not going to get angry at them or
maybe it really was intended maliciously
but they tell us that it wasn't and
that they didn't do so voluntarily and
were like oh okay i'll let it slide and
then later on we find out well then we
could become angry again
he also says something really
interesting here and i think that this
one is perhaps one that we have to
question a bit
those who act the same or do the same
things as oneself
the translation here of phrases all who
behave in the same way to themselves and
aristotle's reasoning there is that
we're not likely to
slight ourselves we're not likely to
insult ourselves spite ourselves um show
contempt towards ourselves that could be
a bit questionable but let's let's just
assume that for the moment so when other
people behave the same way to us
then
we are calm not angry towards them
is this really born out in experience i
do not think so not in ancient greece
and not in our own time if however
we get the person to realize that it's
ridiculous or silly or irrational for
them to be angry
at somebody else for doing exactly the
same things or similar things to what we
do
then i think that's what aristotle's
talking about here so it's not just that
people who do the same thing as us and
we're sort of in a
knee-jerk reaction to them that we don't
get angry with them we probably do but
we can apply this cognitive remedy
to calm people
what happens when somebody does
do things like you know insulting or
sliding
and we get angry well we become calm
and he says those who admit
homologous this means to agree right
literally but it would mean to admit
that you did something wrong so i say i
didn't like that and then you say
oh you're right i shouldn't have done
that that was wrong
and it goes a little bit further
those who we translate this as those who
are sorry if we wanted an older
fashioned
way of translating this it would be
those who
repent of those who
are
bothered by saddened by pained by the
fact that they did the wrong thing at
the greek for this is metamelomenois
and that meta plays a very important
role there's a lot of meta in the
language of remorse and repentance in
ancient moral philosophy not just in
aristotle but also in the stoics and
also in later christian writers
so metanoia changing one's mind but not
changing it like oh i'll have pizza
instead of tacos it's more like oh
i really need to get my crap together
because i'm a bad person i need to
change my perspective so those who did
wrong and admit it and are
repenting or sorry for it in some way
also similarly those who humble
themselves tape a new menois
and who do not contradict
right when one of the tendencies when
somebody
angers us and we
tell them about that is for them to say
oh you're wrong
you shouldn't be angry i didn't i didn't
mean to do it those are ways of
contradicting us it wasn't that bad what
are you what are you so upset about quit
being such a sensitive snowflake right
well uh if you want people to be calmer
don't contradict them
especially don't tell them to calm down
because all of those are ways of showing
contempt sliding so you're actually
making the anger worse by doing that
sort of thing by contrast those who do
humble themselves and who don't
contradict can lessen the amount of
anger and he he has an explanation here
they seem to recognize they are inferior
those who are inferior are afraid no one
who is afraid slights another
is kind of an implausible
reconstruction on aristotle's part but
we could say that
by humbling yourself you are in fact
placing yourself in a lower position
with the other person you're not
lording it over them as you might be
doing if you're contradicting them
another one that uh he brings up
is those who are serious with those who
are taking something seriously or those
who are
being serious spudayos spudayos can mean
a good person it can also mean somebody
who is taking something seriously so if
um you know even if it's something that
doesn't need to be taken seriously like
you know your check engine light comes
on which these days in our cars could
mean basically
anything if they're like oh this is bad
and you're like oh no don't worry about
it's not a big deal you you can make
them angry on the other hand if you're
like oh yeah what do we need to do to
get this fixed can i give you can i
follow you to the to the
repair shop and we'll have them take a
look at it now you're actually
treating them as if the things that
they're concerned with are serious and
that will help to
calm them that will help to not convey
insult or anything like that
another one those who refrain from who
do not engage in
insult hubris right which is one of the
forms one of the main
forms of sliding
that's that's quite important or
mockery right
or
sliding you don't want to be again
putting yourself above somebody else and
insulting them or mocking them or
showing contempt for them and now
aristotle says something really
interesting with this he says
towards three kinds of people he doesn't
use the word three there but there's a
listing that's going on either towards
nobody they don't do this to anybody
right they don't insult or mock or
slight anybody
or
they don't mock those
who are
helpful who are useful prestus who are
good people
or
one doesn't do this to
those who are
one considers to be like oneself
there's something about seeing somebody
who we identify with
or view as similar to ourselves
getting mocked getting ridiculed getting
insulted getting treated badly
that
tends to get us angry
at the person who's doing it you could
say on their behalf but also
on our own behalf
now here we get to one where
i think this is pretty implausible
except for really good people
aristotle says
that um
well actually before that let's talk
about fear and respect this is a little
bit more plausible it says people are
mild towards those who they fear they
feel phobos fear towards
or
uh respect literally a sense of shame in
relation to
why
because it's impossible to be afraid and
angry at the same time and presumably by
extension it's impossible to feel
respect towards somebody and be angry at
them at the same time and he also says
those who show respect to us we don't
get angry at them
the the
feeling fear sometimes fear turns into
anger right
if uh for example students are afraid
that their grade is going to be bad
and they don't quite understand what's
going on sometimes they lash out at
teachers right they get angry at the two
why are you doing this i'm gonna get i'm
gonna report you to the dean i'm gonna
give you a bad review or things like
that
and similarly when when we respect
people if they treat us in a way that we
don't like
we might think that we're really on
their level and get angry but you know
for the most part this is right what
about this next one
those who have acted literally those who
have done things
in anger we don't get angry at them why
not so the argument that aristotle gives
here
seems to be a little bit implausible he
says
those who feel anger do not seem to have
acted
from a desire
to slight other
people
uh ugardi olegurian finontai praxai
why because nobody slights another when
anger since light is free from pain but
anger is accompanied by it
not a very good argument there
it's quite possible that when we are
angry if we examine our own experiences
that we do engage in things that are
forms of sliding we treat others with
contempt we look down on them because
we're angry at them we engage in hubris
or insults right which makes us feel a
little bit better
and we tell ourselves that we're setting
things straight but oftentimes we go too
far with it or sometimes we're just
malicious and spiteful i'll show you you
son of a [ __ ] right
and that is a form of sliding as well
so people who are angry especially if
they have anger problems if they're
vicious with respect to anger as
aristotle would say they often do engage
in sliding not only against the people
they're angry with but perhaps even
against other people as well so this
this idea that those who have acted in
anger we don't get angry with them
doesn't really hold up except if we say
if we ourselves
understand human psychology
and we realize that people are acting in
anger we can say oh you poor
bastard i feel
pity for you or compassion for you
because you're doing these stupid things
anger does tend to make us stupid
aristotle in nick mccain ethics book
seven says anger is like a hasty servant
it hears part of what's being said and
then rushes off to fulfill the orders
that it didn't quite get right
and so anger is like that so we could in
fact feel compassion towards those who
are
angry or mild towards them but it's
probably not the case universally
this is another one that's very
interesting
when they think that they
committed
themselves
adi kane right the word for to to
do injustice
when they think that they did wrong
and have rightly
suffered the cayose which is the
opposite of adike dikaios is an is an
adverb right justly
is to suffer so when you do something to
somebody else
and you realize that it's wrong and
you're like well i did in fact deserve
what uh somebody else meted out to me
what punishment what
retribution what revenge they took
then you you remain mild but
a lot of people
do in fact
do the wrong thing
suffer rightly but don't realize that
that's the case they think that they
did the right thing or at least not the
wrong thing and that they suffered
unjustly and they're going to be still
angry so a lot is depending on this
think or
deem or
judge in this case and then finally when
the retribution won't be known as coming
from oneself this is a very
interesting observation
on aristotle's part here
and i think that there's probably
something to this he actually talks
about this with a few examples he says
people are milder if they think that
those who are being
punished or who retribution is being
imposed upon
will never know that the punishment
comes from them
in requital
for their own wrong and the the word
that he uses here is not actually tim or
racist the uh you know revenge or
retribution it is actually the word for
for punishing
um collado menoy there's kind of some
overlap here and he says
anger has to do with the individual
uh as it's clear from our definition
wherefore it is justly said by the poet
this is homer if you don't remember the
famous uh story of odysseus
and his men who are stuck in the cyclops
apollo mephis's cave being eaten one by
one and they wait till he falls asleep
after they get him drunk and then they
gouge out his eye and they manage to
escape odysseus cannot resist
saying something to polyphemus
tell him that it is odysseus sacker of
cities and aristotle interprets this as
saying
as if
polyphemus would had not have been
punished if he had remained ignorant of
who had blinded him
and for what so aristotle goes on and he
says
people are not angry either with
those who cannot know who punishes them
or with the dead because they've paid
the last penalty and can neither feel
pain nor anything else which is the aim
of those who are angry and then he has
to bring up another example from homer
that of achilles who is angry at hector
angry against a dead man and
you know the the line is it is senseless
clay he outrages in his wrath what is
what is uh achilles doing he's taking
the dead body and dragging it behind his
chariot and riding around to tear it up
because
hector who's now dead killed by achilles
killed patroclus achilles lover
when achilles was sulking out of anger
in his
tent now
this is a very interesting dynamic is
aristotle right about this uh there's
good reason to think that he probably is
as a generalization i mean some people
are cool with um
taking revenge no matter how it it works
whether the other person knows it or not
passive aggressive actions are like that
but in a lot of cases knowing that the
other person is not going to realize
that you're the one
who is responsible for punishment could
make you feel less angry more mild
towards them more calm so these are a
number of important considerations
if we want to understand this emotion of
calmness or mildness that is the
opposite of anger we need to know with
whom people typically
feel this and why
they
feel this emotion
you